الكويت استقبل ولي العهد الشيخ مشعل لاحمد
الجابر الصباح في قصر بيان رئيس مجلس
الوزراء الشيخ احمد النواف وزراء الحكومه
الجديده لاداء اليمين الدستوريه بمناسبه
تعيينهم واكد ولي العهد خلال الاستقبال ان
المصالح العليا للبلاد مسؤوليه الجميع من
قياده وحكومه ومجلس امه ومن جهتها كدا
الشيخ احمد النواف ان الحكومه الجديده
ستقوم بالعمل والتعاون مع جميع اعطيها في
المجتمع الكويتي لتحقيق مستقبل افضل
ضم الينا من الكويت المحلل السياسي محمد
السبتي السيد محمد حياك الله هل في هذا
المشهد اي جديد هل هي حكومه حل لازمه ام
حل مجلس
الحقيقه لا جديد
الاجراءات التي تمت من تشكيل الحكومه وقسم
هؤلاء الوزراء امام اسمه ولي العهد ليس هو
الا استحقاقا دستوريا
واجراءات بروتوكوليه يعلم الجميع ان
الحكومه استقالت منذ فتره طويله وتم تكليف
رئيس الوزراء بتشكيل حكومه جديده ولم يتم
هذا التشكيل حتى شكلت البارحه وحلف هؤلاء
وفق هذه الاجراءات والاستحقاقات الدستوريه
لكن لكل مواقب ان يعلم ان اليقين مستقر في
نفوس جميع الاطياف السياسيه بما فيهم سمو
رئيس الوزراء بما فيهم رئيس مجلس الامه
انه لا تعاون بين الطرفين بل اكثر من ذلك
هناك تصريحات واضحه جدا من كتل نيابيه
انهم لن يتعاونوا مع رئاسه مجلس الامه
الجديده ولا مع يعني الوزراء الجدد
وبالتالي سيناريوهات هذه الاجراءات
لقرار حل جديد لمجلس الامه كما اظن يقينا
ولن يخرج عن هذا السياق ابدا كيف ستكون
للخطوات الوصول الى هذه النتيجه
بلا شك ان هناك خلاف وخلاف شديد جدا بين
الدستوريين وفقهاء الدستور في هذه المرحله
اعني بذلك هل يجوز
للحكومه ان ترفع مرسوم الحل قبل ان تستكمل
يعني اجراءات تشكيلها بالكامل بما في ذلك
القسم امام مجلس الامه
كثير من الفقهاء يرون ان الحكومه يجب ان
تقوم يعني استكمال اجراءات تشكيلها وهذا
يستلزم ان تحضر في جلسه مجلس الامه وان
يقسم رئيس الوزراء والوزراء كذلك امام
مجلس الامه ثم بعد ذلك يكون لهم قد يكون
لهم يعني رفض مرسوم حلم المجلس الامه الا
ان الواضح ان هذا لن يتم
واظن ان كل اجراء سوف يتخذ من الحكومه
الحاليه سوف يكون مطعم كذلك امام المحكمه
الدستوريه في القادم من الايام بلا شك وهو
يعني تكرار لسيناريو سبق ان الحدث عوده
الى نفس المربع دوران حول نفس النقطه لا
يمكن التعويل على اي نتيجه
او توقع اي نتيجه بتكرار نفس الادوات
والوسائل
للاسف بدنا يعني بدنا نخجل من تكرار
كلامنا كنا في الثمانينات كان هناك عنوانا
في الصحافه الكويتيه يحذرون الكويتيين من
لبنانك لبنان من ان نسير كما سار النهج في
الاحزاب اللبنانيه ثم في بدايه التسعينات
اصطلح الكويتيون في الصحافه على ما يسمى
بصومله الدول يعني عدم تكرار
النموذج الصومالي بدنا نخشى ان يقول الناس
ابتعدوا عن يعني كوتته هذه المجتمعات عدم
تكرار هذه التجربه السيئه التي نمارسها
بممارسه يعني هذه الديمقراطيه والعمليه
الانتخابيه بطريقه خاطئه للاسف من جميع
الاطراف
نبقى في ذات المشهد في ذات المربع وكل
خطوه تتخذ امامها كذلك
مئات الطرق من الطعن امام المحكمه
الدستوريه
والتكالب والتسارع في وهل ستظل الكويت تصل
على هذه الطريقه على هذا النهج دائما يعني
بدون اي نتيجه بدون اي لا في حاله واحده
اذا اعترفنا بهذا الخطا اذا تجرعنا مر
الاعتراف بالخطا ما زال كل المجتمع بما
فيها تلك الاطراف الحكوميه او الكتل
السياسيه يعني يستكبرون على انفسهم
الاعتراف بهذا الخطا الذي مارسناه خلال
يعني مده طويله
وحتى لا نجرع على تعديل بعض البنود في هذا
الخطا ما لم نعترف بهذا الخطا يضم كل عاقل
لست انا فقط كل عاقل يظن اننا لن نخرج من
هذا
سيدي الفاضل لماذا يعني نستشهد باقوال
غيرنا قبل يومين فقط عقد رئيس الامه
مؤتمرا صحفيا وصرح النبقاء سمو رئيس
الوزراء خطر على الكويت في كل يوم يبقى
سمو رئيس الوزراء خطر على الكويت ونحن لا
نقر هذا طبعا ولا نوافقه لكن هذا
يستطيع كل عاقل ان يستغرب من خلال المشهد
المشهد واضح جدا نعم اقول ها وبكل مرار
سوف نبقى في ذات المربع سوف تبقى ذات
الطعون سوف نمارس ذات العمليات الانتخابيه
ثم تجرى طعون انتخابيه على ذات النقاشات
التي ناقشناها نحن وناقشها اباؤنا وهم قبل
الاجداد نبقى في ذات حتى
نعترف بهذا الخطا ونتجرع مراره هذا
الاعتراف ثم نذهب الى الطريق الصرع للاسف